hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and I'm doing something a little
bit unusual in the podcast today in the
sense that you know I like doing unusual
things we're always trying to experiment
here but usually every episode is
completely different in topic than the
previous episode and the following
episode but you can think of this week's
episode and last week's as sort of a
matched set last week we talked to Ramez
naam about the optimistic view on our
energy future how we can switch to
renewable energies and really combat
global climate change today I'm talking
to Michael Mann who is a professor of
atmospheric science he's the
distinguished professor of atmospheric
science at Penn State University one of
the most informed and most well known
experts on the bad part of climate
change that is to say how fast it's
happening the evidence for it and the
deleterious effects it's going to have
on our world so I think that because
climate change is so challenging this is
the right order to have these podcasts
in as optimistic as we want to be it's
really really important to keep the
challenges in mind Mike man of course is
famous or infamous for being involved in
all sorts of political controversies in
climate change not really his fault if
you look in it to the information but he
and his co-authors were the author of
the original hockey stick paper and
graph where you could see over hundreds
of years how the earth's temperature had
been more or less static and then was
zooming up in recent times the so-called
hockey stick graph that got him the ire
of all sorts of well financed opposition
people so we talked a little bit about
that but honestly we spend most of our
time in this episode talking about the
science Mike was actually a physics
undergraduate major and so he knows all
I'm a physicist so we dig in a little
bit to the physics of how the Earth's
climate is changing how we know that
it's changing and what we might do about
it even though this is sort of the
pessimistic of the two shows there's
still some reason for optimism here
basically it's in our hands what we want
to do that's always true but for climate
change it's an especially urgent message
remember you can go to the website
preposterous universe calm slash podcast
to get transcripts show notes and links
all
so links to our patreon page if you want
to support the podcast you can get ad
free versions of the episode as well as
monthly asking me anything episodes and
with that let's go
[Music]
mic man welcome to the mindscape podcast
thanks it's great to be with you Sean I
presume that everyone who's listening
has heard of the fact that our climate
is changing a little bit might be
warming up there's storms and things
like that but because of all of that
stuff that were already inundated with I
thought it'd be fun just to start with
taking a step back remembering what's
going on here remembering that there's
something called the greenhouse effect
that we've known for a very long time so
why don't you give us your version of
like the quick and simple here is why
things are changing and why we should
care yeah so you're absolutely right the
basic science here the science
underlying human caused climate change
goes back nearly two centuries those of
us who were trained as physicists of
course appreciate the name Joseph
Fourier and we're a familiar of course
with his fundamental contributions to
mathematics the Fourier series of the
Fourier transform the law of heat
conduction through solids for EA's law
well Fourier actually understood didn't
you know he hadn't worked out the
details but he understood that there
must be a greenhouse effect because the
surface of the earth is warmer than it
should be given the output of the Sun
and our distance from the Sun and so
essentially over the past two centuries
we have been refining our understanding
of the basic science but it's nearly two
centuries old so this isn't old you know
this isn't new controversial science
it's science that goes back you know
farther than the theory of evolution
moreover we would not be able to explain
basic observations like Venus why is
Venus as hot as it is and why is Mars as
cold as it is without understanding the
greenhouse effect
so the basic science behind human caused
climate change the greenhouse effect is
irrefutable in fact in the absence of
any greenhouse effect at all earth would
be a frozen minus 18 degrees Celsius
yeah I think it's a very important point
it's not like the greenhouse effect is
something that we're bringing into
existence it exists and we're tinkering
with it a little bit right and we should
and we should be thankful to the
greenhouse effect because earth would be
a frozen and almost certainly lifeless
planet in the absence of the natural
greenhouse effect natural gases in the
atmosphere water vapor being important
among them carbon dioxide and methane
that have this warming impact on the
surface they absorb some of the outgoing
heat energy that's trying to escape to
space and they send some of that energy
back down towards the surface of the
earth and so that warms up the earth and
it brings it to the relatively balmy 18
degrees Celsius or roughly 58 59 degrees
Fahrenheit temperature that the planet
actually has a habitable planet the
problem of course is that sorry sorry
Mike let me just stop you very quickly
cuz as a physicist I just have to you
know dig into this a little bit yeah the
the amazing thing here is that of course
these same gases are perfectly
transparent to visible light right you
know we get light from the Sun and but
then we sort of process it a little bit
and guess what the entropy increases
this is one of my favorite facts about
the universe and so we radiate it back
as infrared light at a different
wavelength different frequency and these
same gases are opaque to that that's
what causes the heat to be trapped is
that fair that's right it just goes back
to some of our you know or early the the
early semi classical physics we studied
as undergraduates I believe we know uh
the temperature of an object determines
the amount of blackbody radiation it
produces through the stefan-boltzmann
law and so the Sun which has a surface
temperature about 6,000 Kelvin I believe
through Wiens law that tells us that the
the center of the distribution of the
radiation it's producing is in the
visible and so we see the Sun we see the
visible radiation coming from a 600 Cal
a 6,000 Kelvin object whereas the earth
is about 288 kelvins and the same law
Wiens law tells us that the peak of the
distribution of radiation that the earth
is producing the blackbody radiation of
the earth is producing is centered in
the infrared a
completely different part of the
electromagnetic spectrum and what these
greenhouse gases do they can actually
absorb those wavelengths of radiation so
if we were wearing infrared sensitive
glasses and we were looking up at the
atmosphere it would look relatively
opaque to us because those those
greenhouse gases water vapor which is
natural co2 some of which is natural but
we're increasing it by fossil fuel
burning those molecules because of their
vibrational and rotational modes of
freedom are able to absorb and emit
radiation in the infrared part of the
spectrum roughly 0.5 microns wavelengths
of radiation and that is indeed why they
act as greenhouse gases and they warm
the surface of the planet you must have
been a physics major back in the day
this is great I still you know I look
back fondly on those days and in fact I
often find myself drawing upon my
training as a physicist in the work that
I do today and did Fourier or it wasn't
for yet but someone back in those days
did point out you know we're burning
fossil fuels I don't know if they called
them back then but we're probably
putting new co2 in the atmosphere so the
idea that we're increasing the
greenhouse effect is also pretty
venerable yeah that's right and in fact
I believe it was actually a rainiest you
know the the it's amazing these sort of
Renaissance people of science you know
back in the in the 19th century who
could work on so many different
important problems Iranian of course is
known for giving us one of the the
prevailing definitions of an acid so in
the field of chemistry but he also
recognized that you know that there was
a greenhouse effect of course that had
already been established and that we
were probably increasing it by by
burning fossil fuels he he didn't think
that that would be
that much of a problem but he was aware
of the basic science behind it
okay so he turned out to be right now of
course we'll go in I think a little bit
more to the details there but let's just
very quickly say of course there are
also complications right it's not quite
that simple that this is the simplest
basic story and then there are things
that work in extra influences in both
directions that's right you know when
there's a fit you know physicists we
like to start out with assumptions
assume a spherical planet actually
that's pretty good yeah and the Sun so
those assumptions are pretty good but we
have to make of course all sorts of
other assumptions when we we speak of
the the problem and at this level of
simplicity because there always are
complexities we can for example abstract
the earth as a point in space and we can
simply work out the radiative balance of
that point in space of the earth as if
it was just a mathematical point in
space and we would be balancing the
incoming what we call the shortwave
radiation that you know that high
frequency in for is re ultraviolet and
visible radiation coming in from the Sun
and we have to balance that with the
outgoing what we call a long wave that
is the infrared radiation being emitted
by the earth taking into account to this
layer of greenhouse gases and we can
construct a very simple zero dimensional
model that literally a model where
there's no latitude
there's no longitude and there's no
altitude the earth is just a point in
space but we do account for the fact
that there's an atmosphere through our
treatment of the greenhouse effect and
using such a simple model a zero
dimensional energy bounce model you can
come up with a pretty good answer you
can actually estimate the the
temperature of the earth very accurately
using the you know the parameter the
emissivity that measures the the the
greenhouse effect of the atmosphere you
can go further than that you can
actually use a zero dimensional energy
balance model to model the response of
the global average temperature that's
all this model can tell you it can't
tell you the temperature in the
or the temperature at the equator or the
temperature up in the troposphere versus
way up in the stratosphere it can only
give you a single number the average
surface temperature of the earth but it
does a good job with that and you can
actually model changes in the average
temperature of the earth back in 2014 I
published an article in Scientific
American where I used a simple zero
dimensional energy bounce model it's a
it's one of the simplest differential
equations you could hope to write down a
first-order linear differential equation
that you can solve analytically or
numerically if you like and I use that
model to demonstrate the the response
that we can expect of the average
temperature of the planet to various
scenarios of increasing greenhouse gas
concentrations and the numbers I came up
with are virtually indistinguishable
from the numbers that climate modeling
groups using the most elaborate
three-dimensional climate models of the
ocean and the atmosphere in the
stratosphere and the carbon cycle in the
clouds and everything else you can
imagine that are run on supercomputers
they come up with pretty much the same
answer that I come up with that 0
demanding that 0 dimensional energy
bounce model and that scientific
American article and in fact in the
supplementary link you can go there and
download that program and run it
yourself on your PC if you like you
could never do that with a full blown
global climate model but the zero
dimensional energy bounce model isn't
going to tell you anything about changes
in rainfall patterns or ice sheets or
sea level rise or shifting wind patterns
the oneno phenomenon what's going to
happen to rainfall in central
Pennsylvania where I live or out in
California where you live yeah all the
questions we would really like to answer
that models not going to give us the
answers we need so we go to increasingly
more elaborate models that incorporate
you know that account for more of the
processes in the system there's a
hierarchy of models and we see this of
course in in physics physics is well
known for you know you start out with a
simple conceptual model or even a good
Donkin experiment and you build up from
that but but that's where you draw
your intuition about a problem and it
can guide our interpretation of you know
of the problem
it's absolutely interesting to me that
the answer is so close I mean I have a
great deal of you know confidence that
the simple model should be in the
ballpark and then you can tweak it but
we know that there are other effects
that do push but in both directions and
is there some physical intuitive
explanation for why they either do they
balance out or they just all just
smaller than you would think yeah so I
was a bit glib in the way I
characterized it in reality you have the
advantage in a simple model of this sort
that you've got you know a small number
of you know tunable parameters if you
will parameters that you can tweak and
you have the freedom to choose those
parameters in such a way that you get
the right answer so there's the probably
the most important parameter in that
regard is what we call the climate
sensitivity how much warming do you get
for a doubling of co2 concentrations and
our best estimates are that that's
probably somewhere in the neighborhood
of three degrees three degrees Celsius
so a little less than six degree
fahrenheit warming if you double the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere pre-industrial levels were
about 280 parts per million so we will
hit that doubling of about 560 parts per
million in a matter of you know a few
decades if we continue on the course
that we're on and one of the key metrics
of climate change is this so called
climate sensitivity now in a full-blown
coupled ocean atmosphere ice sheet the
most elaborate climate models you can
imagine that is an emergent phenomenon
you can estimate that from actually
putting you know all of the representing
all the processes and seeing what answer
you get in the zero dimensional energy
bounce model that's just a specified
parameter so all of these feedback
processes that we know are important
associated with the melting of ice or
the evaporation of water into the
atmosphere or changing vegetation there
are lots of feedback processes responses
of the climate system itself to the war
that modified the warming and so they
they are positive or negative feedbacks
that have to be incorporated if you're
going to describe the full in nature of
the response of this system in the zero
dimensional energy bounce model we can
summarize all that with one parameter
it's the climate sensitivity even though
we're not representing the ice sheets or
the carbon cycle or any of the things
that actually end up determining that
sensitivity no that's actually very
helpful and I love that you called it an
emergent phenomenon it's actually very
reminiscent or in fact exactly the same
as what we would call the
renormalization group approach in
fundamental physics where there's a lot
of stuff going on underneath the surface
but for the net effect on large
macroscopic scales you can sum it up in
sort of one simple parameter right
exactly yep and but nevertheless there's
still complications we do care about I
mean one that I just got to get out of
the way right away is what do we even
mean when we talk about the global mean
temperature right you know the
temperature here where I live in Los
Angeles isn't even the same as it is in
Pasadena what 20 minute right away where
my office is so how do you go about
doing that average what what really
counts when you say here is the
temperature of the earth right now yeah
so it should really be thought of as as
just a again I suppose a metric it's a
measure of climate change that is useful
in characterizing certain global scale
responses for example sea-level rise by
and large is a function of the average
temperature of the planet there are
various other attributes the total
amount of water vapour in the atmosphere
is essentially a function of the average
temperature of the planet but as you
allude to we don't live in the global
average we live in particular locations
land turns out to warm faster and more
than oceans when you increase the
greenhouse effect and that has to do
with a number of processes but oceans
have more thermal inertia a greater heat
capacity so they respond more sluggishly
to the increasing downward flux of
heating from increased greenhouse gases
whereas the the
the land responds more quickly and so
there is a very large amount of regional
variation if you shut down the North
Atlantic Ocean current known as the
conveyor belt sometimes called the Gulf
Stream although technically speaking the
Gulf Stream is something a little
different it's really a wind-driven gyre
yeah the the the North Atlantic drift is
this water that continues north on into
you know near Iceland and Greenland and
then eventually sinks because it becomes
cold enough and salty enough to sink and
it forms this so-called conveyor belt
this relatively warm surface current
that flows north towards Iceland and
Greenland and Europe and if you shut
that current system down you can
actually get a cooling in certain
regions this was popularized of course
in the film The Day After Tomorrow but
as you know and I I would be surprised
if you actually reviewed that film I
know you know I say la it's one of those
in it's it's it's it's fun you know when
when Hollywood you know and and science
intersect to talk about you know what
they get rot right and what they get
wrong they get a lot wrong you have to
get a lot wrong to take something that
would play out over time scale of
decades to a century and have it occur
in a matter of days and so it's a
caricature of the science but but but
what happens in that film there is a
grain of truth as there always is to the
scenario and if you were to shut down
the the North Atlantic drift or the
conveyor belt ocean circulation you
could get a cooling for example in
Iceland and so you do have to understand
these regional responses changes in
ocean currents changes in wind patterns
and all of that for California for
example what happens to California when
it comes to droughts you know we've
we've seen epic drought over the last
decade a little bit of relief over the
last year or two
yeah well relief if you want to call you
know drenching floods relatively yeah
but yeah yeah I mean yeah we got a lot
of rain here in LA but I'm not even sure
if we're technically out of the drought
yet I think I think we finally are but
it's not exactly as if it's a you know
tropical rainforest around no exactly I
was actually looking just the other day
at the the drought map the current u.s.
drought map and there's a very faintest
yellow which indicates a very slight
drought and a little corner near San
Diego but otherwise the rest of
California is white which is to say it's
neutral it's sort of neither and drought
or or having you know experiencing an
excess of rain so but we've seen epic
droughts and they will likely get worse
more pronounced and more extended as we
continue to warm the planet and and why
that happens you know some of it has to
do with the warming of the soils and you
get more evaporation but a lot of it has
to do with changing Acula atmospheric
circulation the sort of belt of deserts
is located in an area where you have
sinking motion in the atmosphere it's
part of a circulation cell we have
rising motion near the equator and
sinking in the subtropics and that
sinking air is is warm and dry and it's
why you know large parts of California
and other areas in the subtropics tend
to be relatively dry in the winter you
get some of these mid latitude storm
systems the front sort of trailing edge
of the Front's coming down into the
region and that's where you get most of
your rainfall well with the models
predict is that all those patterns shift
poleward so the dry subtropical deserts
shift poleward mm-hm and the
mid-latitude storms the mid-latitude
cyclones that bring rainfall with them
those shift poleward as well that means
that california increasingly large part
of california will find it self well
within sort of the core sort of belt of
deserts and missing a lot of the
rainfall that it used to get in the
winter from these trailing storm systems
but how bad that will get how quickly
that will happen that all depends on
getting you know weather right getting
these weather systems and their behavior
right in these models and that can be a
tricky thing
because whether it's really complicated
there's a lot of chaotic behavior
nonlinear dynamical behavior things that
are you know sometimes difficult to
capture in in a model for example that's
to course in its spatial resolution that
doesn't get the all of the detailed
regional processes right so there are
real wildcards question marks when it
comes for example to you know how you
know what will happen to rainfall in
California there's still uncertainty
about precisely what will happen there
even if we can say California will warm
up and and there'll be less snow pack
and and more evaporation from warmer
soils all of that favors droughts but
what happens to these storm systems that
still sort of up in the air and no pun
intended yeah no I definitely wanna get
into that because I've have some serious
questions I mean not serious like I'm
doubtful but I don't understand but but
first I think that my actual question
was a little bit simpler I just want to
know what it means to say the global
average temperature I mean yeah if the
air has different temperatures both
latitude and longitude wise but even in
altitude like what what is the thing
that we are defining if we imagined
having a thermometer at literally every
point in space in the atmosphere and
then taking the average or is it
something number that yeah yeah you've
put your finger right on it
it's literally if we had a thermometer
everywhere over the surface of the earth
and as you allude to reduce that
thermometer measurement to sea level
because obviously for that elevation
it's gonna be colder so your implicit in
that is the notion that you could define
a surface that would be at sea level
covering the entire planet and and if
you could do that and if you could make
measurements everywhere on land at the
ocean surface and at elevation reducing
those temperatures and you know there
there are various ways to do that but a
dry atmosphere cools at about 10 degrees
Celsius for a kilometer and we call that
a lapse rate and so you can reduce
temperatures to sea level that's the
number that you would theoretically come
up with it by the way is the only number
that is estimated in a zero dimensional
energy bounce model yeah that exactly
is envisioning a temperature that's
measured precisely in the way that we
just described
okay so there's some more or less
agreed-upon procedure for taking the
data we have about the temperature at
different locations on earth and
converting that into a best fit number
that we would call the global mean
temperature yeah that's right and you
got your start as far as I understand it
and actually trying to push this idea
backward in time right trying to figure
out what it had been over time so tell
me how you got into that and how we do
that sure thing yeah so you know early
on in my PhD studies I was interested in
understanding it came in as a physicist
and I was interested in constructing
models for describing the natural
variability of Earth's climate I wasn't
really looking at climate change I was
interested in natural cycles in the
climate that have to do with
oscillations in the way the ocean and
the atmosphere interact with each other
the most well-known of these is the El
Nino Southern Oscillation no one denies
that the the climate does change even
without our help
absolutely and and even and when we talk
about natural climate change there are
two types of natural climate change they
can be externally driven by changes in
solar output or volcanic eruptions that
have a cooling influence on the planet
there are a various natural you know on
longer timescales the ice ages are
driven by changes in Earth's orbital
geometry relative to the Sun so there
are these natural external drivers and
then there's the fact that the climate
like the weather is a chaotic system and
in fact one of the claims to fame of our
field of field of atmospheric science is
that that is where our modern conceptual
understanding of chaos actually arose it
was in a set of equations that my PhD
advisor in fact Barry Saltzman back in
the early 1960s he had been studying
these equations these equations had it
described sort of it was a simple system
for describing
and it consisted of three coupled
partial differential equations and he
noticed that these equations were giving
rise to very unusual behavior he thought
it was some sort of numerical
instability his former MIT colleague ed
Lorenz recognized that there was
something more fundamental going on here
and in Lorenz was trained in sort of the
earlier that work by plunk RA in the
early twentieth century into nonlinear
dynamics and and understood that this
was in fact a real system exhibiting
what had been theorized chaotic behavior
so the atmosphere and weather exhibits
chaotic behavior but so does the climate
the El Nino phenomenon which
Californians of course are intimately
familiar with yeah
that is a nonlinear interaction between
the tropical Pacific Ocean and
atmosphere we understand the physics of
those interactions pretty well and when
you model those interactions they are
described by a set of nonlinear coupled
differential equations that give rise to
chaotic behavior so there's a there's
this chaotic component to the climate
that even if you weren't changing any of
the external parameters just leaving the
system to run on its own it would vary
in this chaotic matter just the same way
that the weather varies chaotically over
time but in this case El Nino is a three
to seven year sort of cycle the weather
you know mid-latitude weather systems
have timescales of days to a week the El
Nino phenomenon because of the longer
timescales of the tropical Pacific Ocean
those oscillations happen on timescales
of years three to seven years I was
interested in potentially longer time
scale oscillations in the climate system
related for example to mid latitude
ocean gyres the Gulf Stream being part
of them these are ocean circulation
systems that sort of have intrinsic
decay --dl timescales
so if there's an oscillation it could
have decayed --all or longer timescales
I was interested in the extent to which
those oscillate those oscillations exist
and it turns out you run into a problem
if you're interested for example in
multidecadal oscillation is like 50 the
70 year cycles there's some evidence
that they may exist then you've only got
a century of widespread thermometer
measurements so you're sort of stuck you
know that's that's basically one cycle
you know you can't really identify an
oscillation you can't do a Fourier you
know you you can't do a Fourier
transform or a spectrum you can't ask
you mate the spectrum of a of a hundred
year data set and hope to isolate a peak
that has a time scale close to the
length of the data set so that led me to
become interested in other types of
climate data they could take us farther
back in time so called proxy records
like tree rings and corals and ice cores
and that's what led me on this sort of
journey which ultimately led to an
estimate of temperature changes over the
past thousand years and the so called
hockey stick curve that placed me right
at the center of the very contentious
battle over climate change but the
questions that motivated that work
actually had nothing to do with climate
change itself that is hilarious I didn't
realize that it came from the Lorenz and
the you know initial forays into
nonlinear dynamics in chaos but it makes
perfect sense in retrospect yeah no it's
a it's and it's interesting the the the
the interplay between atmospheric
science and meteorology and physics it
really goes back to the origins of you
know to some extent of both Sciences so
there is this this very nice
interconnectedness which is appealing to
me because again I got my start in
physics and so a thousand years I
presume that's a non arbitrary number
there's some reason why that's the
reason the regime in which we can
accurately measure the global
temperature is that at the time in fact
in 1998 we published our first estimate
and that only went back 600 years then
based on the analysis of other records
we found that there were enough longer
records that we could actually
obtain meaningful results a thousand
years back and there are sort of
internal Diagnostics that you can look
at it's a statistical problem and
there's statistics that you can look at
that tell you whether or not you're you
know prediction or your estimate is
likely to be meaningful or not and so
you can look at the time of that first
study in 1998 those statistics told us
we couldn't go back any farther than six
hundred years with the data we had and
get a meaningful answer but by digging
into some additional longer records we
were able to extend that back a thousand
years now scientists have literally
extended these sorts of estimates
millennia back in time there's one
tentative estimate of this sort that now
goes back well into the last ice age
twenty thousand years back in time and
now we understand that the the spike of
warming that we found in our study which
was demonstrated the warming of the last
century to be unprecedented in a
thousand years
well these studies now show that it's
unprecedented in tens of thousands of
years and potentially although we don't
have the data to conclude that it's
likely that the warming spike we're
seeing now is unprecedented in you know
hundreds of thousands of years if not
longer and what is there some particular
proxy that is the best I mean what is
the best way to figure out what the
temperature was a thousand years ago
yeah so if you if you want to go back
the nice thing about the timeframe of
the past thousand years or so is that
you do have a number of annually
resolved records which is to say you've
got corals or ice cores or tree rings
that have annual layers and so you can
get an annual chronology and that's
actually very helpful when you're trying
to calibrate these data against modern
records that you can literally align
them and you can do a statistical
calibration if you want to go back
farther than that you start to become
reliant on sort of lower resolution
records sediment cores and pollen these
are things that can be dated but not
annually they can be radiocarbon dated
or there are other methods of dating
that provide rough times
Gayle's but you lose that annual
resolution which creates additional
challenges when you're trying to
calibrate the records against the modern
temperature longtime mindscape listeners
will know that my cat's Ariel and
Caliban play a big role in helping me
make the podcast occasionally their
meows are heard in the background cats
are a wonderful thing overall but we all
know that there is the issue of kitty
litter it's a necessary evil it's not
really fun so I was really glad when a
new mindscape sponsor came along in the
form of pretty litter pretty litter is a
new kind of kitty litter which is
everything you want in kitty litter it's
lightweight because it's made of
crystals not of clay it's
environmentally friendly it has this
wonderful property that one bag will
last you an entire month they ship it to
your house you don't have to go to the
pet store to get it all the time and
it's really good at preventing odors the
best part for me about pretty litter is
that it monitors your cat's health when
your cats are not feeling well pretty
litter will actually change color
depending on what's going wrong with
them so you should do what I did and
make the switch to pretty litter by
visiting pretty litter comm using promo
code mindscape for 20% off your first
order
that's pretty litter comm promo code
mindscape for 20% off say hi to your
cats for me while you're at it
so you alluded to the hockey stick the
fact that right now in the last century
the temperature is zooming up which of
course if you plot it at the same time
as you're plotting the co2 concentration
in the atmosphere that also zooms up and
it's exactly what Fourier would have
predicted I suppose that's right that's
exactly right Shawn I'm glad you you put
it that way because it's really
important for people to understand that
that's how science works it isn't that
we found a warming spike it said ah well
what else is going on
Oh fossil fuel burning that must be the
cause then it's just the opposite we
have understood for so long that
increasing greenhouse gases have to warm
the planet and these observations and
these temperature reconstructions are
simply confirming what more fundamental
science pretty much tells us has to
happen and and that's that's really
important for people to understand
because it's
one way in which science is often
misrepresented right it's easy to create
or strawman these scientists were just
looking for cause and you know and the
two things happen to correlate that's
not how it works well and also one of
the popular responses among climate
skeptics is that there are many natural
ways for the climate to vary and of
course that's true but nothing like the
timescales we're seeing here and correct
me if I'm wrong but investigations such
as yours have helped us understand
things like the medieval warming period
in the Little Ice Age and these are real
but they're more gradual and and we
understand them is that fair yeah no
that's absolutely right and those past
climate patterns we we now understand
quite well those past climate anomalies
if you will the Little Ice Age the
medieval climate anomaly in fact we
we've moved away from calling it the
Medieval Warm Period because it was
actually quite cold in the large part of
the tropical Pacific a Eurocentric there
to call it that's right
and and and we now understand a good
deal of that that what's going on with
these these past natural changes unlike
the warming that's happening right now
which is pretty much you know globally
ubiquitous it is warming happening just
about everywhere over the surface of the
earth
these past periods you might have warmth
in Europe but cold in the tropical
Pacific cold in parts of North America
and what's happening is you're seeing
the response to changes in ocean
circulation patterns and wind patterns
those are things that tend to cancel out
in a global average you're not changing
the overall radiation budget of the
earth like yet are with greenhouse gases
you're just sort of shifting heat around
and increasingly these past periods very
much appear to to reflect those sorts of
changes sort of regionally cancelling so
that if you look at the global average
of the little ice age or the medieval
climate anomaly there are changes in
global average temperature of a couple
tenths of a degree Celsius that are
consistent with the drivers changes in
solar output volcanoes those can warm or
cool the global climate they can change
the global average
temperature but here's they also
interact with these climate modes like
El Nino or the the pattern known as the
North Atlantic Oscillation how the
Jetstream varies over North America and
Europe these these forcings these these
radiative these external changes can
interact with modes of climate
variability leading to large regional
changes that largely cancel in the
global average and if you do the global
average you find that it's consistent
with how the underlying factors are
changing the global radiation budget of
solar or volcanic forcing so it's kind
of the difference between heating things
up overall and moving the heat around
from place to place which at any one
place might seem like a dramatic shift
exactly and and and that's where you
know the modeling and the observations
have really come together because in in
this area of science and in all areas of
science you know that there's always
theory and modeling and then there are
observations and observations are king
you know in the world of physics
observations in our field can be a
little tougher to deal with if they're
not quite as precise as the measurements
that you're able to make and you know in
in in particle physics you know often we
have large error bars on our
observations but but but the
observations and the theory work hand in
hand in in this field as they do in
physics and and that's when you you
start to have a comprehensive you know
foundation for understanding a
phenomenon when the observations and the
theoretical modeling really align and
agree with each other and and we've seen
the science move in that direction when
it comes to you know our understanding
of the Little Ice Age in the medieval
climate anomaly yeah so that's good
let's drag it back then to the present
day and what's going on so obviously
we're dumping co2 and other greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere primarily from
fossil fuel-burning what is the relative
rate of other things I know the cows
burping has a lot to do with the - well
I'm glad you you know you you you didn't
misrepresent the cow
they've been much maligned I know which
end of the cow the yes the cows aren't
in nearly as as flatulent as exactly as
they're sometimes implied you know so
that's that's part of the problem was a
report that just came out I PCC special
report the IPCC comes out with their
major climate reports roughly every five
years and the last one came out a few
years ago there'll be another one in a
couple years but in the meantime they
often publish these interim reports on
specific sort of areas of the science
and in this case they were focusing on
land and part of that was focusing on
the role of agriculture and livestock in
generating greenhouse emissions and it
got a lot of play and you know it's it's
sort of interesting and this is the
topic of the book that I'm actually
working on right now is sort of about
what are known as deflection campaigns
you know if you're the fossil fuel
industry it's very convenient to point
at those poor cows say no they're the
problem or to point at us and say you're
the problem because you're eating beef
and you're eating meat and it's the
problem is on us is is on you rather
it's it's not the burning of fossil
fuels we've seen these sorts of
deflection campaigns many times in the
past when it came to you know the the
beverage industry and a model and can
litter the tobacco industry and and and
and many others well we're seeing that
to some extent with the fossil fuel
industry where there's a grain of truth
you know there's some of those emissions
do come from you know agriculture and
livestock but you know beef is
responsible for only believe it's six
percent or five six percent of total
carbon emissions are associated with
beef livestock and the eating okay
that's a pretty small piece of the pie
we also hear a lot about flying a lot of
criticism well you know flying is 2% of
the carbon emissions it's not zero and
personal responsibility is part of this
and we should all try to do everything
that we can to minimize our own you know
personal carbon footprints and often
those are sort of low-hanging fruit
they're no regrets decisions on our part
because they save us money they make us
healthier they make us feel better and
they reduce our carbon footprint so we
should all do that but when it comes to
the main source of the problem the
lion's share are roughly you know just
about 2/3 of the carbon emissions are
from the burning of fossil fuels for
energy and transportation and we sort of
have to keep our eye on the ball because
we as individuals can't reduce those
emissions if we don't work for systemic
change that changes our entire energy
infrastructure our transportation
infrastructure our you know our energy
infrastructure and to do that we need
policy and we need politicians who are
willing to support policies that are
good for us in the planet rather than
the policies that might make huge
profits for the you know fossil fuel
interests who fund their campaigns and
and so I in my view that's where we
really need to be focusing but let's not
lose sight of the fact that there are
things we can do in our everyday lives
and and you know the reduce our carbon
footprint and these things are
synergistic when we do that we send a
message to others it puts us on a path
of you know engagement where we become
more committed to doing more and to
trying to you know influence policy for
example to solve this problem yeah I'm
actually a huge believer in solving
these kinds of things or tackling them
mostly systematically mostly through
government or international cooperation
you know personal virtue is great but it
can it can it is great I honestly I
shouldn't take that sarcastically but it
also can be an excuse to sort of not
worry about the real bigger thing I did
have exactly I'm doing I did a podcast
interview I'm gonna publish these
back-to-back Ramez with Ramez naam do
you know Raman yeah absolutely sure yes
so he's he gave the optimistic side of
the story because he's all about how
renewables are coming and we're gonna be
driving electric cars and he'll be great
and
counting on you to remind us that you
know it's not automatic and if we don't
actually make an effort to do it then
really bad things are gonna happen so I
don't I don't want to say to you the
pessimistic side of the story but a
little bit of a realist ingredient in
the cocktail here yeah well my mantra
these days is urgency and agency so good
yeah we have an urgent problem and we
need to act and it's not gonna solve its
you know itself it's not gonna the
solution isn't gonna happen on its own
but there are things that we can do and
there are reasons for cautious optimism
it's not too late to make the changes
necessary to avert the worst impacts of
climate change so I imagine that you
know he and I probably agree somewhat
and the bigger picture but perhaps I'm
you know more likely to emphasize the
need of dramatic policy change now and
in particular holding the feet of bad
actors to the fire taking to task bad
actors and the politicians you know in
their you know in their pay who are
blocking efforts yeah literally trying
to make it more difficult for us to
shift towards renewable energy they're
blocking incentives for renewable energy
they're doing everything they can to
throw a monkey wrench into the works and
we need to make sure that they don't get
away with doing that I do want to talk
specifically about the politics and the
policy but what one more important
science thing that I want to be clear on
but you had a relationship of the
overall increase in warming with the
sort of local features of the weather
right I mean more dramatic weather
events have been happening or at least
perceived to be happening it seems like
there are more droughts and floods and
hurricanes now than there were a few
years ago it's not obvious to me that
there's a connection there with warming
but there seems to be so hopefully you
can explain this to us
yeah thanks I'm so glad you asked that
Shawn because it actually relates to
some the research that I've been doing
in recent years I'm best known for the
Paleo climate work and the hockey stick
that I did decades ago but my research
these days focuses too
to some degree on sort of the impacts of
climate change on extreme weather events
and in fact last March I had an article
in Scientific American about the
research that we've been doing that
interestingly enough taps into my
physicist training and background
because some of the mathematics that you
use to solve this problem you actually
use the wkb approximation oh nice all of
my physics students listeners or their
hearts just lettered when you said that
well yeah and it was it's delightful of
course when I encounter you know an
opportunity to actually draw up on my
training even in quantum mechanics you
know who thought that my you know the
study of the behavior of a matter at the
smallest scales could have implications
for our understanding of global scale
you know atmospheric patterns but but
the mathematics work out to be similar
because it turns out that there's a
phenomenon a resonance phenomenon in the
atmosphere and we've seen this in recent
summers if you think about these really
persistent extremes like we've had in
California where the you know you have
one of these blocking my patterns a
ridge a high-pressure system just parked
over California for weeks at a time not
budging or back east we've had the
opposite we've had a low-pressure system
a tendency that get these low pressure
systems that just remain locked in place
normally these weather systems sort of
move along from west to east with the
jet jet stream but as the jet stream
slows and as you change temperature
patterns in the atmosphere you can
actually create a resonance effect where
these systems become stationary and they
grow greatly in amplitude so you get
these really deep highs and they sit
over the same place like California for
weeks on end and that's when you get
record heat and drought and wildfire and
because of the waviness of the jet
stream if you've got one of those deep
ridges high pressures parked over the
west coast there's a good chance you've
got the flipside of that
sinusoidal wave the low-pressure parked
over say the eastern US which is exactly
what we saw a last pattern
last summer and we had unprecedented
rainfall and flooding now what our
research shows is that as you change the
pattern of temperature with latitude so
it turns out that the the Jetstream owes
its existence to the difference in
temperature between the sub tropics
which are warm and the polar regions
which are cold and that north/south
change in temperature actually drives
east-west variations in wind strength
through something known as the thermal
wind and it's a combination of
hydrostatic balance in the atmosphere
and the so called geostrophic law that
involves the Coriolis force and pressure
gradient forces in the atmosphere so
sound sciency I like it yeah no it's
it's really it's fascinating science and
it tells us why the jet stream is
located where it is it also tells us
that if you reduce those temperature
contrasts for example if you
preferentially warm the Arctic and you
don't warm the subtropics as much you're
going to reduce that temperature
gradient that north-south temperature
gradient you're going to reduce the
strength of the Jetstream and that means
that systems are more likely to stay
parked they're not getting sort of moved
along as quickly but they grow they can
grow an amplitude because of this
resonance effect and it turns out that
happens through essentially a waveguide
phenomenon where the mid-latitude are
acting as sort of a waveguide where the
those the undulations in the Jetstream
which are these weather disturbances we
call them Rossby waves or planetary
waves typically they lose energy they
radiate energy both vertically but also
latitudinal E they sort of lose energy
radiating to the south and to the north
but under certain conditions when the
the north-south temperature variations
are just right the atmosphere behaves as
a waveguide there's basically a wall at
sort of the subtropical end and that the
sub polar end and these Rossby waves are
funneled through a waveguide with
minimum loss of energy and it turns out
that the mathematics to
of the for the the dispersion relation
mmm it requires the use of the same wkb
approximation that was using quantum
mechanics in the early 20th century yeah
that's great and so so early 26 re yeah
so in in some sense I mean the the the
atmosphere is not unstable in the
traditional sense like it doesn't you
know we poke it and it runs away to
either zero or infinite temperature but
the it sounds like the sizes of the
fluctuations that it undergoes when it
comes tries to stabilize itself the
amplitude might be increased by the
increasing temperature overall that's
exactly right this is one mechanism by
which you can get these larger amplitude
weather disturbances now obviously there
are other mechanisms that that come into
play so there in limiting you know
there's a limit on how much of that
strengthening can happen and it turns
out in this case it's because what we
call the simple theory the barotropic
theory which is sort of like a
vertically uniform atmosphere ultimately
breaks down because the atmosphere isn't
barotropic and so these eventually this
condition breaks down and so it doesn't
reach infinite strength just like
hurricanes don't reach infinite strength
there are dissipating mechanisms that
kick in when they become strong enough
but the upper limit as to how powerful
they can become whether it's hurricanes
or the amplitude of these weather
disturbances does appear to be
increasing because of climate change yes
I was just gonna say exactly that and
hope that you would agree with me that
it's fair to imagine that we're gonna
get more droughts we're gonna get more
hurricanes we're going to get more
floods we're gonna get more extreme
events as well as an overall increase in
temperature that increasingly no pun
intended appears to be the case and it's
another area or is an area where the
science has progressed when I would say
a decade ago if you would ask me this
question these things were very much up
in the air but you know are the models
have become far more sophisticated and
realistic our observations every day
we're getting new observations
and we've really refined our
understanding of these connections quite
a bit to the point where I think one can
say there is now an emerging consensus
that we will see more extreme weather
events and we will see more intense
hurricanes and tropical systems as a
result of human-caused climate change
and you can't point to any one hurricane
and say oh this is because of climate
change but you can point to a lot of
hurricanes over a period of time and say
yeah this number definitely has
something to do with how we're messing
up our atmosphere yeah that's right and
and in fact we can even point to some of
those individual hurricanes and talk
about how you know not that climate
change caused you we can't say climate
change caused the shortwave disturbance
you know again it's a chaotic system and
and you can run a model ten different
times and get a different result of you
know whether or not a hurricane forms or
not in each of those simulations because
it is fundamentally chaotic but once it
does form and it begins to strengthen we
know that a warming atmosphere warmer
ocean temperatures there's more
evaporative transfer of heat from the
ocean surface which is the energy that
drives and strengthens these storms in
fact colleague of mine Kerry Emanuel of
MIT I think now more than two decades
ago worked on a very elegant theory for
tropical cyclones you can actually model
them as a Carnot cycle nice there's a
sort of cold temperature reservoir at
the the troposphere at the boundary
between the troposphere and the
stratosphere which is sort of the lid on
the rising motion associated with these
systems and the surface of the tropical
ocean is the the warm reservoir and the
efficiency the work done which is a
measure of how intense
in fact the hurricane can become is a
function of the differences between
those temperatures in terms of Carnot
yeah it's a very elegant theory and it's
essentially right and so what happens is
that upper temperature that cold
temperature reservoir pretty much stays
the same but the warm temperature the
surface of the ocean is increasing and
so the efficiency increases
our work is done these hurricanes become
more powerful and so we can talk about
how with a given hurricane it was likely
you know more intense had more water
vapor in it because that's the amount of
water vapor in the atmosphere is another
nice simple physical relationship known
as the clausius-clapeyron equation
basically the evaporative evaporation
rate increases as an exponential
function of the temperature so a warmer
atmosphere for each degree Celsius the
atmosphere holds about seven percent
more water vapor and so we can say that
these storms have more moisture in them
that means more moisture to turn into
record flooding rain falls like we've
seen over the last two years we've seen
the two worst flooding events on record
for the US and that was with Harvey and
then with Florence well okay I mean so
why don't we just remind our listeners
of all of the terrible things that's
going to happen I mean again I'm not
necessarily you know I want to get later
to the policy soon to the policy but
because we can do things to change
things but it is good to keep in mind
how bad things will get if we don't
change anything I mean so there's
extreme weather events there's also
rising ocean levels there's changes in
crops and farming what is what are the
things that you fret about when it comes
to climate change the most yeah I the
things that keep me up at night are are
the things where there is uncertainty
right too often we hear uncertainty
offered by the critics as a supposed
reason for inaction oh well we're not
sure so why should we do anything well
from a risk management standpoint it's
just the opposite of that and it's
especially true that's especially true
because the the uncertainties have been
cutting against us if you look at the
projections say you know a decade ago
and you look at where we are with
respect to the melting of the ice sheets
and the rise in sea level or many other
measures the loss of sea ice in the
Arctic
we are seeing changes that are at the
upper end of the uncertainty ranges that
we had put for it at every juncture yeah
and and and what that tells us is that
uncertainty has not been our friend as
we've resolved that uncertainty it's
turn you know it's turned out that you
know the processes that we hadn't
represented very well when you get those
in the muscles into the models they
actually tend to for example accelerate
some of these processes a good example
is ice sheets in the old day an ice
sheet was treated as just a huge mound
of ice mm-hmm but we understand they're
very dynamic in fact you know you can
use a modified sort of set of fluid
dynamics equations to describe the
flowing of ice and the constitutive
behavior of ice it has a complex
dynamics to it I can collapse you have
ice cliffs that can collapse you have
ice shelves that provide buttressing
support for the ice sheets you have
cracks that form in the surface that
allow meltwater to rush to the bottom of
the ice sheet where it lubricates the
base it allows the ice to surge more
quickly out to sea and so as we get more
of the physics into these Ice Sheet
models we're finding that they're more
dynamic and that they can collapse
faster and we're seeing that and we're
seeing sea level rise faster because of
it so you know uncertainty is not our
friend and that's what keeps me up at
night it's the fact that there is
uncertainty and and certainly can take
the form of the known unknowns as you
know infamously once described by a
political figure you know they're the
known unknowns and the unknown unknowns
and the things that keep me up at night
are the unknown unknowns that are
lurking out we know they're out there
and we just haven't discovered them
because the known unknowns have worked
out to not be in our favor that's likely
to be true for the unknown unknowns as
well well but what about the known
knowns I mean we know the the sea level
is rising right I did I'm sure that
you're safe in central Pennsylvania I
did check that here in LA our high
above sea level is enough that even if
all the ice on earth melted we would
still not be under water but some of my
friends on the beach are not going to be
quite so lucky is that going to be worse
overall for the planet than the simple
fact of the temperature is going up or
does it just depend on who you are where
you are yeah well I mean sea level rise
is certainly proceeding faster than we
expected and it's true you know if you
live in Jersey Shore Pennsylvania you'll
be fine there's our town called Jersey
Shore in the middle of Pennsylvania that
I Drive through and ever I try for East
and if you live on the Jersey Shore of
New Jersey a different story when I grew
up when I was growing up and I had
grandparents in Philadelphia we would go
to the Jersey Shore in the summer and if
you live on the Jersey Jersey Shore
you're familiar with it or you know
anywhere along the mid-atlantic coast
New York City for that matter we're
already seeing Miami Beach you know it
might even be the best example there is
increasing talk about managed retreat we
may be essentially beyond the point
where there are any adaptations building
levees or other means of preserving some
of our large coastal cities we may have
to literally retreat from the the
coastline and obviously as there becomes
less land available and that can be true
because of sea level rise literally
eroding our coastlines reducing the
amount of you know of coastal land or
the the the amount of total land and
you've got the tropics becoming
potentially too warm for human beings to
occupy so you're talking about seven and
a half billion and growing people
competing for less space less food and
less water now that doesn't keep you up
at night you're hot you're not thinking
about it because this really represents
a potential crisis from a security
standpoint from a
inflict standpoint that's where the the
scenarios that we that even you know our
military experts have gamed out some of
these scenarios you know and some of
them don't look unlike the the post
apocalyptic the dystopian futures that
Hollywood has depicted that we of what
you know our future could look like if
we don't get our act in gear and what is
your feeling about the current people
political solutions the Paris agreement
and so forth I mean solution is not the
right word but at least strategy for
trying to do better I mean is it is it
enough if if we actually all did what
the Paris agreement said we should do
would that be enough or is that just a
little stopgap yeah it would guess by
halfway to the emissions reductions we
need to avert warming of two degrees
Celsius which most you know scientists
who study the impacts of climate change
will tell you if we warm the plant more
than two degrees Celsius a little less
than four Fahrenheit that's where we
start to see some of the worst impacts
irreversible impacts of climate change
increasing and how much have we warmed
it already we've warmed it about one
point two degrees Celsius already so
when you hear there's a lot of target
about to talk these days about the two
degrees Celsius target but also a lower
one and a half degrees Celsius target
because if you're a low-lying island
nation that's already you know
catastrophic warming we will probably
lose many of our low-lying tropical
island nations and other coastal regions
we may lose the Great Barrier Reef at a
warming of one and a half degrees
Celsius so there yeah you know credible
arguments for saying that two degrees
Celsius is too much we shouldn't let it
get above 1.5 degrees Celsius well do we
we've already done one point two oh two
so that tells you there isn't a whole
lot of wiggle room left is there and if
someone put a gun to your head when
would you predict we would hit the two
degrees Celsius warming mark they don't
have to put a gun to my head in my 2014
Scientific American article using that
zero
energy mounts model I made a prediction
of precisely that it's sort of business
as usual if we do nothing then by 2036
or so we hit the data we hit that number
and so that tells you that's 2 degrees
Celsius one and a half degrees Celsius
comes earlier and you know we're warming
the planet at about point almost 0.2
degrees Celsius per decade so if I tell
you we're at 1.2 and actually more like
0.25 per decade and we're at 1.2 and
we're trying to avoid you know 1.5 we
get there even even sooner
so in fact yeah we're warming closer to
0.2 degrees Celsius I should say and and
so we got point 3 degrees Celsius to
work with there and the US I yeah
the US is the worst I forget which way
it goes the US is the worst per capita
or the worse overall we're the worst per
capita the average carbon footprint of
an American is about 20 metric tons of
carbon that's the weight of two large
African African male African elephants
that's the the mass of co2 that the
average American is putting into the
atmosphere a year and you know carbon
footprints are literally orders of
magnitude smaller than that for most of
the developing world increasingly
countries like China and India as they
industrialize are approaching a more
American sort of sized footprint and
that's obviously a big part of the
problem as well arguably that's why
those of us you know in the West the US
Europe who built our economies on you
two centuries of free access to dirty
energy we obviously have a major
responsibility if we're going to tell
other countries like China and India
that they don't have the same right to
that you know cheap energy to build
their own economies if we're going to
tell them
that they don't have the right to do
that we've got to have her own house in
order and and that's part of why it's so
important for the u.s. to lead on this
issue of course under the current
administration and I'm not sure how much
you want to get into the politics of
this
we of course lack that that leadership
and that's a real problem well I think
we can you know state objective facts
our current leadership has essentially
said the word it's not going to follow
the Paris Accord that we agreed with
resin well yeah in fact you know our
current the current occupant of the
White House has characterized climate
change is a hoax perpetrated by the
Chinese obviously that's not a good
starting place for a meaningful
conversation about solving this problem
do you but do you think do you get a
feeling because I'm sure that you are
involved in a whole bunch of
international events here do you think
that worldwide people are gathering the
determination the willpower to try to do
something about this or is it maybe a
little too little too late kind of
feeling now I I do and part of why I'm
optimistic is the way that our young
folks are sort of taking control of the
the public discourse
you know the Youth Climate movement and
there's gonna be a huge march next month
in New York City the Greta Sundberg this
famous sixteen year old girl from Sweden
but there are other prominent figures in
the Youth Climate movement who have sort
of really helped to reframe this in the
manner that I think it needs to be
reframed this is a matter isn't just
science and economics and policy this is
ethics this is a matter of
intergenerational ethics our ethical
obligation to not leave behind a
degraded planet for our children and
grandchildren for future generations and
it's you know I the the fact that young
folks are now speaking up about this I
think that's a game changer
I think it's reframed the conversation I
think it's a big part of why we are
going to act in time we don't have a
whole
wiggle room as I already said and it's
it's it's the 11th hour but we're also
seeing a lot of progress we're seeing
the reframing of this problem in the way
that it needs to be reframed as a
existential threat and an ethical
obligation to act now and we're also
seeing remarkable changes in sort of the
the energy marketplace we are seeing
exponential rise in renewable energy
electric vehicles California of course
leading the way but providing a you know
providing a blueprint for what the rest
of the states can do and I think we're
gonna we're going to do it I'm
encouraged by the progress we're seeing
but I still fully cognizant of the
uphill a challenge up hill battle that
we face here that we really do need to
to get off fossil fuels quickly if we're
going to avert catastrophic warming of
the planet well there's also the issue
that is closely related to this of
course but the issue about how science
is done and how the discourse over
science is done I mean I know I'm sure
you have a long set of things to say
about this you've been heavily
politicized and year probably was it
completely out of the blue when you were
attacked in various ways or did you sort
of see it coming as soon as you started
working on climate change yeah you know
I can tell you for certain that when I
double majored in applied math and
physics at UC Berkeley and went off to
Yale to study theoretical physics I
didn't think that I was rabble rouser
it's just you know political debate but
when I moved into climate science and
when really when our work started taking
us in this direction when I realized
that our work on paleo climate did have
implications for climate change with the
publication of the the hockey stick
curve back in the late 1990s it became
clear to me at that point that I was
probably you know given the history and
of you know how other scientists who
were prominent in the climate change
had been attacked and vilified by fossil
fuel interests and in front groups and
and and and hired sort of hands that do
their bidding I sort of started to
suspect that I might have to deal with
some of those attacks and and ultimately
when the hockey stick did become this
icon in the climate change debate you
know because it tells this simple story
you know you have to understand the the
physics of the climate to understand
what's telling us that there's a
dramatic change that's afoot and and
that we're responsible for it that was a
threat to the powerful vested interests
that don't want to see us you know move
away from our addiction to fossil fuels
and and and I realized pretty soon that
I may find myself in their sights a
central target of their effort to
discredit the science and so that ended
up you know taking here in a completely
different direction from the one I
imagined when I again when I started off
in physics it isn't what I envisioned a
life in science looking like but that
having been said ultimately I've come to
embrace the opportunity that that's
given me it isn't that yeah it isn't the
the role that I chose it isn't the path
that I signed up for but it's given me
an opportunity to help inform the
societal conversation about you know
perhaps the greatest challenge we face
as a civilization I feel privileged to
be in that position I did do a podcast
interview with Naomi Oreskes and it was
it was merchants of doubt it was you
know quite an eye-opener like I hadn't
actually been familiar with her work and
the the this is the thing that I think
that we don't understand if we don't
follow these things closely is that
these controversies don't just
organically appear all the time right I
mean in billions of dollars of profit
and income are at stake where there are
vested interests it just makes perfect
sense that there will be a concerted
effort to affect the way these things
are talked about and the most bizarre
thing to me is the idea that people seem
to push with a straight face that
somehow climate scientists are
financially benefiting
from pushing a global warming story
clearly these people have no idea how
science actually works now that's
exactly right and part of the problem
here is scientific illiteracy and the
fact that the public doesn't really
understand you know what scientists do
how science works and so it's possible
for bad actors to put forward these
narratives that we know are silly and
they know are silly right people making
these are against no it's silly but it
sounds credible to somebody who doesn't
understand that oh your grants they
don't go to your pocket they may fund
your research program your your
publications and it's really easy to
take advantage of you know
scientifically illiterate you know
relatively scientifically illiterate
Society and it's interesting I was just
reading a book about the life of Carl
Sagan Carl Sagan the life bikie a
Davidson it's a fascinating read and you
know and and and Sagan the prophecies
you know prophesized this he he worried
about precisely the future that were now
in where the we have a public that's so
poorly informed about basic matters of
science that they are vulnerable
especially vulnerable to the forces of
pseudoscience which was Sagan's primary
worry but but moreover of anti science
concerted efforts to to misrepresent
science and to confuse the public in
policymakers about science and its
implications we're living in that world
now it's it's the very world that Sagan
feared we we might find ourselves in
it's a it's a chilling it's really a
chilling prophecy its chilling to to
read what he had to say about these
matters decades ago because his worst
fears are sort of coming true and and
this is a manifestation of that if the
sign you know if the public doesn't
understand how science works and if
there's a concerted effort to discredit
science to to attack the integrity of
science and scientists and we've seen
those efforts that's an effort to
undermine the the
the trust that the public has in in
scientists and what they have to say so
I think we have to recognize that the
challenges we face whether it's in
climate change or in science writ large
are part of a larger problem which is
sort of the lack of good faith in our
public discourse and the emergence of
true fake news and alternative facts and
the challenge that represents to those
of us who who deal in a world of facts
yeah you know I think no matter how
depressing it gets that certain people
are resistant to facts people are not
rational right there's tribalism there's
confirmation bias there's a whole bunch
of thing right but at the end of the day
we have correctness and truth on our
side I think that's a very very powerful
weapon
so I insist on being optimistic about
where things are gonna go as long as we
do great I think that that is you know
ultimately I think that that will win
out but in the meantime you know we have
a real challenge ahead of us all right
Michael man thanks for fighting the good
fight and thanks very much for being on
the podcast Thank You Sean it was a
pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]